[Music]
you're in mississippi
and everywhere you go tamales
those magical little snacks of corn
flour and meat packed into a corn husk
tamales tamales tamales
so if you've ever wondered what
mississippi tastes like
it tastes like me
the tamale
[Music]
my journey starts almost 100 years ago
it's 1930
and mexican migrants are trickling into
mississippi
they bring along a taste of home
their version of the sandwich
me
the tamale
my great-grandfather came here from
mexico city
jumped the trains ended up in
mississippi he decided to make his
family's homemade hand-rolled hot
tamales and in 1939 opened up this place
and started selling tamales
you have to understand this is a family
thing i'm the fourth generation
these same generational people who've
been coming to the big apple in for the
last 78 years are also generational when
they eat a tamale they always have a
story my daddy used to bring me here his
daddy had the same kind of story his
daddy had the same kind of story
tamales caught on here and it became a
staple in the city
so there i am winning over the
mississippi natives and as i make my way
up into the delta
my location may change but little did i
know that the tradition of family
most certainly would not
just like gino and his grandfather at
the big apple inn i bring the scott
family together a family who has gone on
to be known
as the first family of tamales in
mississippi
in the early 50s my father bought the
recipe from a mexican guy my mother and
father taught me
my sisters and my niece all of us
together we're making hot tamales we
just one big katamale family
any business that's family oriented i
think it'll last longer
[Music]
much like the scott family
the dough family is made up of a long
line of tamale makers
dough's eat place is a landmark
restaurant that helped propel me to
become the backbone of mississippi
cuisine i've become today
[Music]
my daddy started this restaurant in
1941 with my mother we've been here 76
years
mama had a
sister that was living here and daddy
had a couple of two or three sisters
that were living here so they all came
enrolled tamales
you know a lot of people ask ask us you
know how did tamales get prevalent in
the delta
it's been family you know the family's
been here all the time
as tamales made their way from mexican
culture to african-american communities
and on to mississippi's white population
there's one thing that remained a
constant
family
the most southern concept of all
[Music]
you